[Música]
Vladimir Putin pensó que sería cosa de
unas pocas horas que en apenas unos
pocos días Ucrania estaría totalmente
Bajo su control según sus planes el
ejército ruso avanzaría a toda velocidad
y ocuparía aquí fen apenas unas pocas
jornadas y su gobierno abandonarían la
capital el ejército ucraniano se
rendiría y todo estaría Listo para el
desfile de la Victoria putín tendría su
gran hazaña y Ucrania volvería a estar
bajo el control de la madre patria Rusia
también encontramos algunos uniformes de
desfile por lo que esperaban llegar aquí
en dos días y luego hacer un desfile
aquí Así que ahora podemos decir que
hemos destruido completamente sus planes
olexander crucevich jefe adjunto del
Estado Mayor de las fuerzas terrestres
de Ucrania sin embargo el curso de los
acontecimientos no pudo ser más
diferente los ucranianos resistieron
Contra viento y marea la ayuda
internacional llegó a una escala
impensable y el ejército ruso tenía más
agujeros que un queso gruyer el
resultado no nuevo desfile de la
Victoria sino que un año después la
guerra continúa y Rusia ha sufrido una
cantidad gigantesca de bajas tanto de
equipos como de hombres
[Música]
según las estimaciones existentes más de
180.000 soldados rusos habrían muerto o
resultado heridos tan solo durante el
primer año de la invasión hablamos de un
promedio de casi 500 bajas cada día
además en tan solo 12 meses de guerra el
ejército ruso ha perdido más generales y
oficiales de alto Rango que en siete
años en Siria o los soviéticos durante
sus 10 años de guerra Afganistán y para
colmo Las bajas sean cebado sobre todo
con muchas de las unidades mejor
entrenadas de Rusia Como por ejemplo las
tropas aerotransportadas o la Infantería
naval Pero eso ni siquiera es todo
fijaos en noticias como esta según las
estimaciones Rusia podría haber perdido
más de la mitad de sus carros de combate
en Ucrania hablamos de más de 2.300
tanques y en total según el recuento
llevado a cabo por la inteligencia
británica Rusia también habría perdido
más de 4.500 vehículos blindados de todo
tipo 63 aviones 70 helicópteros 12
buques navales y cientos de sistemas de
artillería y hablamos tan solo de las
pérdidas que están relativamente bien
acreditadas Es decir un auténtico
desastre
para que os hagáis una idea pese a todos
sus intentos y para asombro de todos los
ejércitos de la otan Rusia ni siquiera
fue capaz de tomar jarquín una ciudad
situada tan solo 50 km de su frontera y
uno de sus principales objetivos durante
la invasión Sí a ver no nos equivoquemos
es cierto con sus misiles y su
artillería Putin está destrozando
Ucrania ciudades como Mario pauls
así lo atestiguan pero sabéis que pese a
todas las pérdidas sufridas por el
ejército ruso Útil no ha logrado ni uno
solo de sus principales objetivos el
gobierno esquí parece más fuerte que
nunca la supuesta unificación de la
nación es lava ha sido un rotundo
fracaso ucraniano ha caído y para colmos
sus lazos con occidente son mucho más
fuertes sus ejércitos está mucho mejor
armado
ahora bien quiere decir todo esto que el
dictador ruso Vladimir Putin podría
estar dispuesto a dar su brazo a torcer
pues lo siento pero parece que no
[Aplausos]
cumplido un año de la invasión según el
Secretario de Defensa británico bengo a
las Rusia tiene actualmente el 97% de
sus fuerzas de combate desplegadas en la
Guerra de Ucrania y pese a ello Lo
cierto es que ningún bando parece tener
la victoria al alcance de la mano ni los
rusos pero tampoco los ucranianos
entonces La pregunta es cómo demonios va
a terminar este infierno de qué forma se
puede poner fin a la Guerra de Ucrania
qué escenarios están sobre la mesa de
las grandes cancillerías internacionales
Pues bien veámoslo
pero antes dadme solo un segundo porque
me gustaría contaros algo la familia Hoy
es el politik vuelve a crecer si el año
pasado nació visual economic ahora lo
hace not news un espacio 100% gratuito
que nace como una newsletter y pronto
como una web y mucho más las noticias
amigos se suceden cada minuto sin
embargo nuestra vida no cambia ni mucho
menos tan rápido por eso nuestra
intención es centrarnos en el contexto
que explica las propias noticias el
complemento perfecto aviso al político
os podéis registrar gratuitamente en dos
news.com y por supuesto si queréis más
siempre podéis sumaros a la comunidad de
patreon Gracias a todos los que nos
apoyáis ya podemos seguir mejorando y
creando proyectos como este Mil gracias
desde aquí y ahora sí continuemos
en busca de la puerta de salida
a comienzos del mes de octubre del 2021
se celebra una importantísima reunión en
el despacho más importante del planeta
el despacho vale entre otros estuvieron
presentes en la reunión el presidente de
Estados Unidos Joe biden el director de
la Cia William burns el asesor de
seguridad Nacional de la casa blanca y
el jefe del Estado Mayor conjunto de las
fuerzas armadas el general Mark Miley
Cuál fue el motivo de la reunión pues ni
más ni menos que analizar las últimas
informaciones de inteligencia que
señalaban que Vladimir Putin podría
estar a punto de invadir Ucrania no
hablaban de conjeturas sino de
informaciones el riesgo era
completamente real hablamos de comienzos
de octubre del 2021 Casi cinco meses
antes de que finalmente las huestes del
kremlin se lanzaran sobre Ucrania Pues
bien en aquella reunión tal y como ha
confirmado el propio milei se acordaron
cuatro líneas de actuación
había que evitar a toda Costa un
conflicto armado entre Rusia y la otan
segundo de producirse la guerra habría
que hacer todo lo posible para
contenerla dentro de los límites
geográficos de Ucrania tercero resultaba
clave fortalecer y cohesionar la otan
había que [__] el teléfono lo antes
posible y cuarto y el punto posiblemente
clave no sólo de la reunión sino de todo
lo que hemos vivido después había que
empoderar a Ucrania y darles los medios
para luchar
sí queridos amigos de visualpolitik esa
fue Ni más ni menos que la reunión en la
que Estados Unidos decidió que esta vez
no miraría de perfil si Rusia
quebrantaba la soberanía y la libertad
de Ucrania los ucranianos no serían
abandonados a su suerte Esa fue la
reunión en la que se fijó la estrategia
que luego poco a poco se ha ido
desarrollando y que junto a la
solidaridad de muchos aliados europeos y
sobre todo por supuesto la tenacidad la
resistencia y la valentía de los
ucranianos han permitido que Vladimir
Putin se haya estrellado contra un
enorme muro
[Música]
y continúa siendo libre los aliados
internacionales han apoyado Ucrania y en
total han comprometido más de 160.000
millones de dólares en ayuda militar
humanitaria y financiera una enorme
cantidad de recursos que tiene que ser
capaz de cubrir las necesidades de este
país hasta finales de por lo menos 2023
nadie pensó que los rusos comenzarían
una guerra medieval en el siglo XXI este
conflicto va a cambiar la cara de Europa
tanto como lo hizo la Segunda Guerra
Mundial James Rich senador republicano
por Idaho y miembro del comité de
relaciones exteriores del senado pero
evidentemente aunque el hecho de que
kiev siga libre es una gran noticia la
guerra la destrucción y la aniquilación
de vida sigue siendo un escenario
terrible Así que la pregunta es qué
salidas puede tener la guerra Pues bien
aquí os dejamos Cuatro Caminos para que
la guerra llegue a su fin por supuesto
No todos son igual de deseables algunos
de ellos Empezando por el primero sería
terrible para todos atentos
[Música]
Uno dejar caer a Ucrania
Putin contaba con que el resto del mundo
no hiciera absolutamente nada que el
resto de países se quedaran de brazos
cruzados viendo como imponía su voluntad
en un país que él mismo no considera
como tal Y sabéis que eso en cierto modo
todavía podría ocurrir ahí tenemos por
ejemplo los casos de Trump y su entorno
en Estados Unidos de podemos en España o
de le pen en Francia y claro no nos
engañemos si se cortará el suministro de
Ucrania tarde o temprano lo más probable
es que este país terminará cayendo o en
el mejor de los casos negociando un alto
el fuego y sería todo una victoria para
Putin y un desastre para Ucrania de
hecho el cansancio de occidente sigue
siendo una de las grandes bazas del
líder Ruso y lo que en buena parte
explica por qué demonios sigue r que R
con su plan y eso es lo que explica
porque el viaje de biden aquí fue tan
importante como una Clara manifestación
de compromiso amigos amigas abandonar
Ucrania supondría dejar a los ucranianos
bajo el yugo de Moscú o en otras
palabras frente a un montón de represión
y purgas de todo tipo los cientos de
cuerpos en muchos casos torturados Debut
son un buen ejemplo pero no sólo eso
también sería algo catastrófico para el
resto del mundo
pensadlo bien estaríamos diciendo a
todos Los Tiranos del planeta que no
solo tienen barra libre para hacer lo
que les plazca cuando les plazca sino
que además los hechos consumados y la
política de la fuerza son la mejor
garantía de éxito poned ahora esa
reflexión en lugares como Taiwán Corea
moldavia y tendréis la mejor receta para
el peor de los mundos
[Música]
precisamente por eso esta opción está
completamente descartada
[Música]
lo que nos lleva directamente a la
segunda salida atentos
dos congelar la guerra
primero la ofensiva rusa y luego las
contraofensivas ucranianas en el primer
aniversario de Invasión la guerra se
encontraba ya en una especie de cierto
letargo al menos desde el punto de vista
territorial los grandes choques han
limitado a puntos muy concretos como
bahamut los rusos han enviado muchos
miles de hombres nuevos para reforzar
sus defensas atrincherarse e intentar
así defender el territorio conquistado Y
sí Es evidente que Las bajas que ha
sufrido Rusia han sido enormes pero
Ucrania también ha sufrido una
gigantesca cantidad de bajas tanto
militares como civiles y aunque ha
recibido mucho material militar todavía
no parece suficiente como para ganar
claramente la guerra si los aliados
mantienen su apoyo pero reducen las
entregas el conflicto podría alargarse
durante años y llegar incluso a
congelarse además todo apunta que el
propio paso del tiempo favorece esta
salida el agotamiento el cansancio la
pérdida de atención social y mediática o
el miedo a otra crisis energética
podrían hacer que muchos países
terminarán buscando una salida cómoda
esto es intentar congelar el conflicto y
en cierta forma si recobrar una parte de
la normalidad
[Música]
Incluso si Rusia termina lanzando una
ofensiva logra nuevos territorios y
luego pidiera alcanzar un acuerdo de paz
es posible que muchos países presionaran
aquí para que esto se llevara a cabo y
sabéis que la propia Ucrania podría no
tener más remedio que aceptar la
presencia de Rusia en su territorio y
una sensación permanente de miedo y
frustración seguimos repitiendo que
Rusia no debe ganar pero qué significa
eso si la guerra continúa el tiempo
suficiente con esta intensidad las
pérdidas de Ucrania se volverán
insoportables alto cargo francés en
declaraciones al Wall Street journal por
supuesto además esto supondrían
muchísimo más dolor durante mucho más
tiempo para los ucranianos y desde luego
no está claro el futuro que tendría este
país realmente se podría reconstruir
Ucrania y atraer a los capitales
extranjeros y las empresas si el país
técnicamente continúa en guerra tiene
parte de su territorio invadido y la
amenaza de Rusia continúa parece difícil
y claro No podemos pasar por alto que la
economía Ucrania está hecha trizas y que
sus infraestructuras están muy pero que
muy dañadas es decir que esta salida
podría suponer una condena a medio plazo
la incapacidad de que el país fuera
alguna vez viable además no podría Rusia
volver a retomar su ofensiva dentro de
unos pocos años cuando Ucrania esté más
debilitada y ellos se han conseguido
restablecer parte de su fuerza militar
aunque sea a base de entrenar reclutas
ojo que ese es un riesgo real
[Música]
en cualquier caso serían cierto modo una
victoria para Rusia una victoria menos
Clara pero en última instancia una
victoria se habrían anexionado buena
parte de Ucrania y al final pues la
comunidad internacional no hubiera hecho
mucho más allá del efecto gaseosa del
principio para evitarlo Pekín está
observando de cerca para ver el precio
que Rusia paga o la recompensa que
recibe por su agresión lo que está
sucediendo en Europa hoy puede suceder
en Asia mañana Joan stoltenberg
secretario general de la otan y ojo
porque de no incrementarse el suministro
de armas Ucrania este escenario es
bastante probable y quizás la mejor
salida para Rusia y tal vez también para
el propio Vladimir Putin por eso dos
aliados como Alemania o Francia dos
países que no están particularmente
cómodos con la guerra que cada uno
piense los motivos se han convencido de
otra alternativa la tercera posibilidad
para poder poner fin a los combates
atentos
3 pensando en 2024
amigos amigas en 2024 hay elecciones en
Rusia y por eso Putin y su entorno
podrían ser los mayores interesados en
alcanzar una salida al conflicto antes
de esa fecha no sea que un revés militar
y económico pues ponga en tela de juicio
su continuidad al frente del kremlin es
decir si la guerra no ha terminado
muchos círculos rusos podrían presionar
para quitarse de en medio a un
presidente fracasado para colocar a un
nuevo líder al frente aprovechando lo
que técnicamente pues sería el fin de
mandato del presidente ruso Pues bien
para evitar ese escenario Putin podría
estar dispuesto a negociar y hacer
concesiones eso al menos es lo que
parecen pensar tanto del presidente de
Francia Manuel macron como el canciller
Alemán Hola Sol Eso sí para que todo
esto sea posible Ucrania tiene que estar
en disposición de hacerle daño a Rusia
lo que exige la entrega rápida de muchas
más armas leopars tanques pues por ahí
van los tiros lo que necesitamos ahora
es que Ucrania Lance una ofensiva
militar que haga retroceder el frente
ruso para abrir el camino para un
retorno a las negociaciones Emanuel
macron presidente de Francia y quizás ni
siquiera haría falta esperar a 2024
una ofensiva ucraniana en el sureste
capaz de alcanzar el mar de azov
recuperar todo el área de saporicha y
poner a crimea a tiro de la artillería
podría ser suficiente para forzar una
negociación Esto es lo que se conoce
como la teoría del Big Bang
ahora bien de llegar a una salida
negociada nos podemos realmente fiar de
que Rusia cumpla su parte del trato pues
lo cierto Es que la historia nos dice
que no Ucrania de hecho es un buen
ejemplo no olvidéis que la propia Rusia
garantizó en el memorándum de budapest
la seguridad y la soberanía completa de
Ucrania Incluyendo crimea a cambio de
que este país le entregará sus armas
nucleares porque amigos amigas al
disolverse la unión soviética Ucrania se
convirtió en el tercer país del mundo
con más armas nucleares
por eso a cambio de estas posibles
negociaciones los países occidentales le
darían a Ucrania una seguridad mucho más
tangible el suficiente equipo militar
como para desincentivar cualquier nueva
agresión en el futuro hablamos de
blindados modernos misiles una fuerza
aérea y todo lo que sea necesario
Incluso se podría plantear un acuerdo
con la otan y como estaríamos hablando
de una salida pactada el país podría
intentar volver a ponerse en marcha
de esta forma Ucrania podría quedar
blindada y tener futuro a cambio de
ciertas sesiones en un acuerdo que
aunque malo Sería mucho más asumible que
el del escenario anterior esta Parece
ser al menos la percepción del tándem
París Berlín que según dicen hoy por hoy
Londres tampoco ve del todo mal además
Ucrania así no corría el riesgo de lo
que pudiera pasar en 2025 si se llegara
a producir un cambio en la casa blanca y
ojo porque a día de hoy este puede ser
con mucha diferencia el final de la
guerra más probable Claro que todavía
nos queda otro posible camino uno con
muchos adeptos en Ucrania Polonia los
países bálticos y también los Estados
Unidos de América de que estoy hablando
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
4 la victoria a cualquier precio
el 2023 empezó con muy buenas noticias
para Ucrania hablamos del compromiso
para entregarles decenas y decenas
cientos de vehículos blindados entre
otros mucho equipamiento incluyendo
tanques modernos hablamos de bradleys
strikers marders amx10 Challenger 2
leopards baterías Patriot etcétera
etcétera si estas entregas se mantienen
y se incrementan con el paso del tiempo
el curso de la guerra queridos amigos
podría cambiar por completo
especialmente si se entregarán más
jaimars más tanques y misiles de largo
radio y no digamos ya si se les proveerá
de más y mejores aviones y drones Y es
que a ver inicialmente se fue muy
comedido con la entrega de armas para
por ejemplo no tener que asumir una
derrota ante Rusia si finalmente
ucraniano aguantaba Y qué queréis que os
diga tiene todo el sentido y otra forma
la otan hubiera quedado muy tocada y el
liderazgo de Estados Unidos
terriblemente cuestionado por supuesto
las implicaciones en el resto del mundo
hubieran sido enormes sin embargo ahora
las cosas son completamente distintas
[Música]
según muchos informes el ejército ruso
podría estar exhausto y falto de
equipamiento lo que explicaría porque
les cuesta tanto realizar cualquier
nuevo ofensiva Es verdad que Rusia ha
enviado muchos hombres nuevos gracias al
reclutamiento pero también Es verdad que
la fuerza de combate de estas unidades
pues no parece particularmente la más
alta es por eso que una sucesión de
fuertes contragolpes del ejército
ucraniano podría hacer saltar por los
aires las líneas de defensas rusas es
decir que sí que puede existir la
oportunidad de ir a por todas derrotar a
Rusia y obligar a su ejército a
retroceder e incluso abandonar Ucrania
tal vez con la única excepción de crimea
de esa manera el daño para el régimen de
Putin sería potencialmente irreparable y
claro La pregunta es Pero qué es lo que
hace falta para conseguirlo Pues
básicamente un apoyo militar mucho más
grande y decidido por supuesto esta
estrategia por un lado podría poner de
nuevo sobre la mesa del riesgo nuclear
Pero de eso ya os hablamos en un pasado
vídeo aquí en visualpolitik os contamos
Por qué era improbable que Moscú
realmente recurrir a esa posibilidad
básicamente porque no ganarían nada Pero
por supuesto el riesgo existe sobre todo
porque en segundo lugar este escenario
pondría en Jaque al mismísimo líder ruso
evidentemente perder en una guerra
contra un país mucho más pequeño y menos
recursos pues no es un plato de buen
gusto más aún cuando la modernización
militar y el volver a hacer de Rusia un
país fuerte y grande fue la prioridad
número uno del régimen de Putin durante
más de dos décadas además si algo nos
dice la historia es que un régimen tiene
muy pero que muy complicado sobrevivir
cuando pierde una guerra
y sabéis qué pese a todas las bajas y
todo el dolor sufrido hoy por hoy esta
sigue siendo la opción con más
partidarios en la propia Ucrania
muy explícito
[Música]
queridos amigos amigas estos son los
cuatro escenarios posibles Para que
veamos terminar la Guerra de Ucrania Ya
veis que en cualquier caso las mejores
salidas parecen exigir que se le
entreguen muchas más armas al gobierno
de Kid Esto es algo casi todo el mundo
parece haber entendido Incluso el propio
olabsol pero o sea como sea del turno es
para ti qué estrategia te parece más
interesante seguir Qué harías tú de
tener que tomar la decisión déjanos tu
respuesta en los comentarios y hablamos
debate y ahora si este vídeo se ha
resultado interesante no olvidéis darle
al botón de like y suscribiros y también
esta vez a not news Muchas gracias por
estar ahí un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]